this is Wizards only fool it's the way
we said the titles fools well there's
only one person most likely watching
right now in a room so oh no you're very
nice I'm sure you're very kind
are you making fun of the people no oh
no not alleging with no no no no very
nice cool people
okay cool you're watching me and now not
that there can't be some part of you
that's cool or no they're cool because
we're watching me so there you go
but Wizards Only Fools um okay so this I
found this one pretty interesting
actually and going in it's like you
already know what we're probably gonna
go with this but well I'll give the lead
for the episode uh PB is there she's
treating with star cheese is named uh
and he says no I only want magic that
that's my belief it's magic or nothing
and she says there's no such thing as
magic it's just a you know different
kind of science that they call something
else and and make up some hobbly gook
you know he says you know you're making
fun of my beliefs I need magic so they
decide to go to the oposite called again
The Wizard City the Wizards how can I
forget them
I'd which first night cuz in my head is
like you know whatever one the alleys
from Hogwarts or something like that oh
really
out of all the things in the history
that has dealt with magic in one way
shape or no no but it Harry Potter for
it okay anyone that watches me no I I'm
not a big Harry Potter guy line examiner
outside of the book thing you know
throwing your hat and get no excited and
there was a humor doesn't get forgotten
there's anything I don't want people to
take out of this I don't I just I never
I never read the books I don't know
books join the books the most part yeah
yeah they're a lot better than movies
okay so we got we got this we got
so they go in and they try to get this
quote-unquote cold spell and PB just
cannot accept that there's from one
James from Ron James and just cannot
accept there's a magic at all she
demands what is the potion made out of
what scientifically makes it happen
and they get called out that they're not
wizards they get thrown in jail and what
abracadabra
well what was this Amy where's Erica
damn Daniel Daniel okay okay got it
close he came back we get that really
up group of wizards our planet
god knows what okay there is an end to
that I I'm glad there I really want to
know what they're after
good they look like fun I mean it's like
we all get hits and pieces of them but
it's like every time I see him I'm like
again like what is their story I'm like
and you always seem to find out a little
more there we're gonna sacrifice Africa
Daniel um but at least it looks like it
but so he gets um but they get found out
the other wizards escape Peebles and
Finn and Jake and abaca Daniel II got
thrown into wizard jail and abracadaniel
challenges her to a duel
fighting Forks pretty much and whatever
that is claw and it's like a chicken
foot yeah some sort of chicken foot and
and they fight but it turns out the cold
spell was really a cold spell which is
it makes everything cold um that allows
them to escape and then they just trick
starchy into thinking it's magic when
really it's not and it probably didn't
work out just like you know hey what's
going on I mean most likely didn't fall
for it so there it is um
on the surface it seems like just a kind
of silly episode but if if you're
reading what I think you're reading it
to this I I heard a lot of replace magic
with religion was very much what I was
hearing and I mean as someone who's
agnostic you know I Stephen Colbert puts
an atheist without the balls oh okay I'm
kind of stupid now what is it
not agnostic means okay you to people
who don't know it traditionally means
without choice you know like that's what
the word technically means but it pretty
much means you don't know you're not
anything you're not an atheist you're
not Christian you're not anything I was
raised Roman Catholic
you know and came around to but I liked
all the religions I like the
philosophies I like the idea it's not
like the history so I serve it and you
know as I get older and older I sort of
go all right and pride that seems
unlikely I doubt this app and stuff but
I still really believe in a lot of their
teachings I think they're fascinating
and and I like the culture I like how
much is brought to it and you know what
I like about is that much like a lot of
things in life for all the you know
whatever really bad things are prejudice
things in stuff there's also a lot of
good there's a lot of love there's a lot
of compromise which is what it's
supposed to be when done right and you
always come across someone who is
diehard you know I want religion
everything about religion for everybody
which on the one hand I understand
whilst I say well on the one hand I
understand because there are some
extremes that just push it so hard and
they put all their insecurities and
their hatred into you know into a
religion because usually because they
come from a background where you know
things are very complicated they didn't
have what they needed and now here's
something where all the answers are here
and it's kept simple because things are
made very difficult for you so this is
something simple so people gravitate
towards that and if anyone tries to make
that simple thing complicated or a
challenge it it's making their life
complicated which they came from but
they don't want that something like no
simple
it says hate this so I'm gonna meet this
it says love that I'm gonna love that
and it's always a shame because I think
all these people are trying to get
something you know really nice and enjoy
life and and try to find that simple
beauty and instead it gets wrapped up in
this mess wow I really went off there no
they do it you've got yeah I'm not gonna
tell you to stop me but Bible one this
is your show so I'm not gonna tell you
to stop at all but uh
but but it does come down to you know
when I guess when I see that happen I
see no difference between you know an
atheist pushing that there is no God
then whatever Christian or Catholic
saying there is a God you know you must
believe this um if you're an atheist v
you're Christian Buddhist whatever fine
uh my thought is always try to get the
best out of what out of any belief you
know what that means you know and
somewhere that means you know sort of
love and kindness and reason you know
and not just blindly following something
following sin that makes sense but also
leads to something productive and good
and all that fun stuff
um but people don't see that they see
I'm just hearing this it's only this so
I'm just gonna reject it and that's
where what I was getting out of people's
in this one and she couldn't see the
compromise that okay if they call it
something else they believe it something
else and it does kind of seem like an
extreme for what we know I mean I don't
know how this world works maybe there is
magic oh it's a strange enough world you
know but for me there is a scientific
reasoning for it too you know now reason
for everything so um but yeah it's sort
of these you know two extremes colliding
uh and I thought the only thing I don't
know about is the end because I would
have liked her maybe it would have been
too obvious I don't know I would have
liked a little bit more if maybe she
came to a compromise cuz the cold spell
happened she goes wow like she didn't
expect that and then she just kind of
goes back and uses you know science like
nothing that much came of it which oh no
it's not like she can't use science or
anything you know but there's I was
trying to figure out whether or not she
actually learned anything out of this or
that was even the point whether or not
you're supposed to learn something it
seemed like you're supposed to but I
don't know about that but I I like stuff
like this that's very much acknowledging
you know just respect police it's not
even if you really really don't believe
in it you know the same way you don't
want someone else to force you know
their beliefs on you you know just just
keep a distance be respectful um so yeah
that's my spiel I love about like
holistic
well aside from bad maybe no honest
that's exactly what I saw my only
problem is is that I'm talking about the
episode right yeah it's that starchy
only wants magic how can you get into
wizard city only if you're a mage so
there's a slight problem there in that
who are they gonna get to go to there to
get it when it's only wizards when the
Wizards are so unaccepting of everyone
else they won't even let them into the
town and if they do come into the town
what happens maybe it landed - what yeah
so let's say people's want to go there
anyways to get this free spell to help
starchy the moment she's found out even
though she's trying to help someone who
believes it and what happens they she
gets tossed into jail and especially for
not for being a non-believer magic - you
know and he says all you have to do is
say that I'm right and you're wrong yeah
so you know you're right I think it is
sir these two extremes then you know
it's kind of harsh it's one of those
where yeah people's is a scientist and
these guys believe in magic and all that
stuff but neither side is bending to
each other yeah that was sort of VAS or
my thing at the end to it and maybe
that's the point maybe it's just like
nobody will her learn anything from this
maybe I don't know but it's like I don't
know it didn't seem like he came around
to serve like this very you know logical
deep thinking wow yeah that made sense
or even just a dumbbell joke that you
know just took all of that and said haha
we're not going there it just sort of
seemed like while there was kind of a
dumbbell joke it's like okay just there
it is I mean my problem with most modern
TV shows or movies or whatever all that
stuff anytime they do go down this route
of religion versus non religion and all
of that stuff in the end it always seems
that the non-religious person is going
well there may be God but the religious
person is never seen going well there
might not be a God it's always that the
non-religious believers are bending and
yes
using quotes because I'm not you know
they're always kind of bending and
having to give in to the believes that
there may be a God you know what you
just said that about people's why
couldn't people's just attend say well
maybe it's magic well why couldn't any
of them say well maybe it's just science
yeah I didn't do that
at least they had people's going wow you
know but but even then it's like what
what's kind of learned from that I mean
it's it doesn't seem like much he's
impressed by it but doesn't say it's
quote-unquote magic it's still very
scientific explanation yeah or whatever
but yeah it is strange that just nobody
bends in this but it doesn't seem like
that's the focus either like there's a
good thing or a bad thing or whatever
it's just like nope nobody's bending and
that's just all we're gonna say about it
you know it's not even like the main
focus of it um well no no no here's
where I was gonna go and this may be a
bit touching and I'm not trying to push
buttons it's just for me when I saw this
the first time it's what popped in my
head is that recently especially in the
news there are parents that are not
treating their kids for sicknesses
because of God's gonna heal them my
religions gonna heal them and all that
stuff and these kids are dying and
that's kind of what this kind of was
where start she's like no I want to be
healed by magic and she's like well I
don't have it deal with it I have
medicine right here that will heal you I
only want that and then you have I think
it was nurse poundcake going you know
you're not being being very sensitive
you know magic healed blankety-blank and
it's one of those words kind of like
what people's supposed to do step back
and be like that's fine I can't get the
magic for you because I'm not a wizard
and I'm gonna let you die or get
incredibly sick or if she's supposed to
trick starchy and heal him you know I'm
not saying one way or another because
that's a person's belief and all that
stuff people can bring up the whole wall
you need to take care of your kids or
what not I'm not trying to make a
comment on that but that's what kind of
came to my head is that when four people
so he runs an entire country if you will
an entire city when is religious belief
overpowered when should religious belief
be overpowered by
yeah there is definitely because I sir
forgot that's a thing but but it is and
I've heard about that too we have the
whole thing you know not treating your
kids and stuff um and I think that's the
the key word is that it's kids not
adults if that's your own belief it's
like fair enough whatever you know I
mean we'll do what we can but you know
um but yeah with the kids it's like that
that's kids you know I mean some of
these Karen it's like well you have to
take my wave you want them to live it no
no it's part of God's plan um and yeah
what yeah well what is the point where
it's pushed to an extreme you know it's
like cause it's not a scientific you
know formula that says you know at this
point it's an extreme at this point it's
not you know again yeah you just have to
practice doing a reason um I really love
this story my dad told me the story of
like you know it's it's this woman in a
house and this flood is coming and this
car comes it says lady you gotta get out
of there floods come again she shows up
God will save me the car takes off and
then the water gets a little higher and
you know a person a boat comes the lady
guy get out there you know come with us
up God will save me and the boat takes
off and that gives us the very group
that helicopter comes it's Lady Gaga she
goes up God will save me and helicopter
leaves the water takes her she dies
she's in heaven sees God and says why
didn't you come and save me he says like
dad I set you have a car I said you have
a boat I said you the helicopter and
that seems very much like that's a good
compromise in my way until God comes
down with his finger says no no it's
cool I got this
yeah you know it makes it better then
I'll totally accept defeat on that don't
get me wrong but you know you have to
you know God works in mysterious ways
you know and you have to accept what God
is giving you you know if you are gonna
have that belief so it I mean it
definitely seems like an extreme to me I
me honestly I'm going for people that go
that round one thing I always find very
interesting in the whole religious
aspect is the whole okay kids died in a
car accident on the way to the hospital
or or you know an old lady or you know
any of these bad things happened you
know you have someone a religious faith
for the most part and they'll be like
well you know God is
and you know God doesn't need us
intervening or whatever but these are
the same people that turn around when
they're you know parents are dying they
put them on all these machines
hmm isn't that kind of against what you
were just saying there's you know it's
it's one of those they kind of pick and
choose I mean you have to pick and
choose oh that's yeah but it's you know
it's a mix to me it's a mix of love
kindness and reason you know yeah there
has to be some sense of reason you know
and hey this is how the world's gonna
work if I put my right foot in from me
that my left I will be walking you know
there's some things are just
straightforward this is how they are if
you don't call Walker you call it
something else this is still how it is
and if I was to get to the door the best
way to do it seems to be walking you
know it's like there's just some things
that are kind of nosey like cartwheels
or flips that would be on us but still
but I can't do that yet so my option is
walking that seems to be the best option
so I will do that maybe one day I'll
learn how to do cart wheels and stuff to
the door but I don't know that yet so
I'm going to walk as that seems to be
the best way to do it and the most
practical um and that's yeah but that's
just using reason so it's I mean I know
you're saying with not stepping on
people's toes and so on so forth I mean
and this buddy's talking about extremes
to and and where do you draw the line it
is tricky um tricky tricky - here we go
but I get yes I like of it there are two
extremes in this at first it's like I
know it sounds strange I wasn't sure
about the wizard world but it's like
you're right they're good it's it's
incredibly obvious actually I don't even
know how I couldn't see if they're
constantly if you don't believe we're
gonna throw you in jail we're gonna blah
blah blah um so okay it is strange it's
just nobody nobody bends nobody learns
anything and like I said because it's
not the focus it doesn't seem like there
was much to get out of it if it was
trying to say yes and nobody will ever
learn anything that's just the way the
world is
I could actually totally buy that but
it's it's sort of just drifts his focus
away and kind of I don't know I guess
finds a compromise
ish at the end it's I would have liked
the stronger ending on this one um I
much like to fin being affected by the
you know underpanties I didn't like that
I liked it when he asked the question so
she make it under there you know cuz you
know like everybody's like wait because
you see an hour come out but then
there's another arm and I'm like yeah
house is working um I did love that
outfit though the way it were the way
you couldn't figure out how it worked
even the outfit under it so in the Tron
oh yeah I thought was very funny that's
that's why the funny is coolest outfit
I've seen that I'm just getting away
from all the serious talk because I know
they're gonna be like god you spent a
half hour talking about bullcrap what
about the actual episode this is I think
this is something the episode is
bringing up I think it is a big part of
it I'd be shocked if it wasn't you know
I mean it really seems like that's the
direction they're like it said it could
see holistic medicine though like
Eastern or alternative forms of medicine
instead of religion they constantly say
like faith and beliefs and stuff like
that so I mean which I know is part of a
listing medicine too but you know it's
it feels like religion but yeah that's
that's my interpretation you know so if
the peanut gallery could say something
oh no so what other things I really
liked about this was the ice King's
appearance oh come on the ice King's
like completely invisible
watching out for this shining down and
then and then like the guys go and throw
the books up along with the ice cream
he's like whoa boy that was just oh
sorry
what my my last serious comment was it
seems Doug's comment that it was very
the focus wasn't on this big
inflexibility of the two sides okay
you're gonna talk this much you got
coming okay your new Jason oh I'm you
Jason hi no the whole Doug's
comment of Jason is doing a sexy dance
in the background
that's great Doug's comment about the
background nature of this inflexibility
between both PV science and then the
magic community makes my interpretation
of it seen that it is meant as an
observation of something rather than
actual and the fact that it is
open-ended me that is not so you're not
supposed to you supposed to get out of
it what you see nah it's not supposed to
give you a solution to it it is
something that you're supposed to take
make take your own solution from it
rather than basically the Creator saying
here's the situation this is how we
think we're supposed to fix oh they're
saying here's the situation interpret it
how you feel based on your belief but
don't you feel because I honestly feels
going more for that angle oh stop oh
that's good okay move over no cuz I need
to comment about that well hold on but
before you that I do want to say - is
that oh yeah OCD say honestly if it took
that route that there are no clear
answers I'd actually be fine with that
it's that it sort of didn't seem to keep
that focus at the end it's like well
she's just gonna kind of do this and
that's that you know like put this way
from the first like minute of the
episode wait you should respect police
huh okay if she just went came back and
distracted him and did the syringe thing
again how would that have been different
than them going to the kingdom you know
the the wizard town you know I guess I'm
saying like you go through all that I
felt like there should be a little bit
more of some sort of conclusion even if
it is there's good there's no clear
answer but it seems like the focus just
sort of vanished there I felt for me my
going off of what you said that's a
cop-out that's like going I think so
well like what he was saying how there
was no clear answer one way or another
it's kinda like going up so and saying
hey do you like the food I cooked for
you yeah well no don't give me this cop
out of the whole thing of well maybe I
did maybe I didn't it's a guess or no
freaking answer no no no I I don't know
if that's true because I feel like you
know there are
of things that are right you know
whatever life is now to find the right
answers it's about answering questions
yeah yeah but no they're the right
question you want an actual decent
answer not a half-assed one okay what I
don't know about that sometimes I think
if you just ask the question and say you
know what let's just get the
conversation going
you know but keep focused that we are
starting this conversation you finish it
yeah you know that that's why I'm saying
but to me I didn't tell you I didn't
feel as quite doing that at the end it
is it felt to me like anyway that they
lost focus no but that's what I'm saying
like they may have asked a question but
they never answered it they kind of like
stopped they they were going towards an
answer like an answer or like a
compromise even and then it just kind of
stopped I don't think you you don't
technically need an answer I don't know
what I would have liked would have been
maybe a burka Daniel doing the whole
doing the magic and at the same time for
poking and he would not notice it
exactly that's why okay there's that the
science and magic are working together
to heal someone and all about okay but
they couldn't even do that it's like no
we're just gonna leave it kind of
open-ended and that deal with it the
only thing I can think is maybe they
were doing that think thinking that we
knew they were gonna go that direction
and then they yanked us out like no no
he knows and it's just a cop-out you
know like maybe the cop-out is the joke
I don't know why but yeah I felt like
the focuser here but I I'm with you if
they leave it open-ended like you're not
supposed to know that's fine I don't
feel that's what they were focusing on
at least at the end that the rest of the
time I can definitely see it because
there are two extremes yeah but yeah I
didn't get so much out of the end but
but you say you did you yeah I got kind
of you know they're doing the whole the
magics there they're making it feel
better and then they have you know the
the science doesn't the cure in you they
don't really go into you know because
that's the over you know has been a
venture time has very abrupt endings you
know there isn't really much time to
explain you know they're both doing it
and then maybe not the same you know
exactly the same time but they're in the
same kind of at the same each time and
though I think the spacing was almost
set up more as a joke so like oh we're
gonna use magic too
don't we're gonna poke you with the
needle I think that was meant more as a
joke just then and then an actual
statement for the ending and another
thing is this is a kids show we're
reading really deep into it is there
yeah then I mean it's it's this is some
well-hidden just out there in the oh boy
but I mean just think you know people
our age and I say our age loosely
because you guys are I'm okay with that
yes but no rank people you know most
most adults don't look into watch a kids
show and try and get a feel of a
philosophical discussion out of it
they're looking to say oh it's stupid
it's for kids we're not gonna think
anything about it i reaiiy see jesus
every single time I see a Bugs Bunny
cartoon I'm sorry I don't know what you
guys see well Jesus was enough for Teen
Hunger Force there you go well I'm sorry
the Kanekalon Jesus they call them the
j-man
the chain but without even knowing if
like cartoons are art anything that you
do is art art can be interpreted however
you like whoever you want I mean so I I
do like how this show is combined so I
only talk abouts before so much like
comedy that's a really heavy adult stuff
you know that I've remember year
especially I was just like damn you know
when I saw that episode yeah so yeah but
that is one of the things I really do
like about it and people live brought up
with the comments well you're calling it
a kids show you how to go together
what's a kid show they bring up you know
anime and all that stuff it was like
yeah to a certain extent animate is
aimed at kids but not all anime is aimed
at kids
well you can't look at every single
anime and go just because it's
hand-drawn or its CG or whatever that
it's meant towards kids the thing for me
that reason why I'm saying that this is
a kids show it's because of the rating
is because of who it is targeted toward
yeah it's gonna be advertised during
kids programming not during adult
programming but adults can clearly watch
it talk about like how we're talking
about it sometimes make a V walk series
out of it you know that mute O's I crazy
people nut balls probably believe in
magic
yeah does the oh by the way for the
record I am atheist God so you have no
balls apparently I have no balls
I heard from Stephen Colbert I love that
term so yeah closing thoughts um I liked
a lot of the characters in the
background yeah I did like Finn with the
wall
I know I totally give a bad I like the
wizard prison I thought that was cool
yeah I was waiting to see underwear
Underpants at underpanties oh yeah and
then uh Jake's like let's go to Daisy's
Tinka blood and then it's the next day
tink - yeah I liked it no matter how
much religion or lack of there is in
this or people are reading too much into
it yeah I thought yeah okay episode a
little bit of fun here in there and I
love the title I liked a lot even if
like I say I don't filthy it I didn't
feel the ending quite got a satisfying
conclusion even if it was meant to not
be a satisfying conclusion but I really
liked it I liked the discussion I like I
like starting kids off young kids with
this discussion I think it's a good one
to start I think this is a good way to
start it and I think it's worth I think
it's worth bringing up and the last
funny comment to mention when the Grand
Master Wizard oh just exclaimed because
Peavy wouldn't catch what it wouldn't
sit wouldn't say it you know she just he
like up a cat was a hairball well
no actually one thing I completely
forgot to mention was one point I was
with her we were with our friends ebb
and we were talking about food being
prepared all over the world you go to
some you like country and they're like
taking a chicken and putting into water
boiling water and be feathering it that
way no problem you know hitting it on a
rock to you know make it more tender
Yatta Yatta Yatta
no problem question that somewhere else
imagine you seen your food prepared here
in the US like that most people would
flip the hell out because how dare you
what about standards when PB goes to get
the ice spell or the cold spell what she
do
she just wants to know what's in it hmm
I think couldn't even give her that
answer yeah it's like going to a store
and saying I want some our McDonald's I
like my burger well what's on it
uh it's just a burger but what's on it
you know she's asking was is what's in
the bottle ya know if I had you
definitely a reasonable question you
know and and I'm sitting up on PB said
look just tell her what the hell say no
no I agree you know that's another
extreme for me so I'm sorry sweetheart
Peebles was in the right oh it's only a
fool no sorry science only hold on if
you're gonna talk you need to be in this
- come on come on oh that's nice gun
well just get the whole bit oh oh man
there we go
oh yeah now we have our Christmas card
yeah yeah science wave Merry Christmas